Mr Beast is going to be worth over a
hundred billion dollars so let me give
you an idea of what Beast Industries is
all about in terms of the ecosystem
across like four five six YouTube
channels he's got 183 million
subscribers on top of that he's got Tick
Tock he's got Instagram he's got Twitter
and in aggregate he's got over 300
million plus subscribers on the business
side he's got Beast Burger which is a
ghost kitchen which basically leverages
the network of restaurants that already
exist and then he uses his distribution
base of customers to buy stuff on an app
the next thing he's got Beast gaming
which is where he'll try and make apps
and video games because he has a big
gaming audience but I think we're the
real winner for him is going to be and
this is what I would make my bet on is
that he's going to be going all in on
feastables